[Música]
Isabel II tuvo el reinado más largo de
la historia británica tras su pérdida
Carlos III se ha convertido en El
Monarca en el jefe de estado del Reino
Unido sin embargo queridos amigos esta
sucesión es un asunto que va mucho más
allá de las Islas británicas porque
Carlos III también es el nuevo rey de
otros 14 países repartidos por América y
Oceanía algunos tan importantes como
Canadá y Australia pero esperad que hay
más Carlos III también es el nuevo jefe
de la commonwealth una organización que
agrupa a 56 naciones soberanas entre las
que se incluyen países como India
Pakistán Malasia Nigeria y Sudáfrica por
eso el 9 de septiembre todo el planeta
estaba pendiente del Palacio de
buckingham la expectación en torno al
discurso del Rey fue enorme
[Música]
en su discurso Carlos III puso mucho
empeño en subrayar que nada va a cambiar
respecto a su madre
[Música]
sin embargo en la era de las redes
sociales su principal problema es que él
no es su madre Isabel II era una figura
muy querida y ampliamente aceptada y el
nuevo rey que quieres que os diga no
parte con esa mochila por eso la
pregunta es qué podemos esperar de
Carlos III del Reino Unido Cómo puede
afectar a la cama en Wells y por tanto a
la influenza británica Este cambio en su
liderazgo puede acelerar la conversión a
repúblicas de algunos de los 14 países
más allá del Reino Unido sobre los que
reina la corona británica Pues bien hoy
en visualpolitik vamos a responder a
estas preguntas pero antes antes vamos a
ver un poco de historia
[Música]
la araña negra
1917 nos encontramos en plena Primera
Guerra Mundial los goza bombardean
Londres y no no se nos ha colado ningún
guión de Mega project sobre estos
bombarderos pesados de la Aviación
alemana los gotas son importantes porque
por aquel entonces el Imperio británico
estaba Regido por la casa de sajonia
coburgo y gota vamos una Dinastía más
alemana que las salchichas de Frankfurt
como os podéis imaginar en plena guerra
con Alemania esto nos hacía ni pizca de
gracia a los ingleses de tal forma que
el rey Jorge V el bisabuelo de Carlos
III se dio cuenta de que su propia
supervivencia y el futuro de su familia
como soberanos británicos pasaban por
renunciar Sí o sí a todos sus títulos
alemanes y como decimos por aquí en
visualpolitik dicho y hecho así de bien
lo reflejó Leonard Raven Hill un
caricaturista de la revista pants de
esta forma nació una Nueva Dinastía los
windsors renunciando a lo que eran Y
adaptándose a lo que se uno de ellos
como Monarcas del imperio posiblemente
esta sea la mejor enseñanza que Carlos
III ha podido sacar de la historia de su
familia una lección sencilla pero
complicada de llevar a la práctica tal y
como demostró el tío abuelo de Carlos
Eduardo VIII que renunció al Trono para
casarse con wallis Simpson por aquel
entonces un amor imposible al set está
una mujer divorciada ahora bien Carlos
III tuvo en casa a una gran maestra en
el oficio de la realeza
[Música]
Isabel II cumplió la perfección durante
siete décadas con el papel de reina
experta en el arte de hablar mucho y
nunca decir nada absolutamente nadie en
estos 70 años pudo reprocharle haber
roto con su deber de permanecer neutral
en el debate público ni siquiera lo
hicieron los nacionalistas escoceses
cuando ante el referéndum por la
independencia celebrado en 2014 la Reina
Isabel recomendó a la gente pensar mucho
sobre su voto
Carlos ha sido el príncipe de gales
durante 64 años ser el Eterno heredero
ha hecho que esté siempre bajo los focos
lo sabemos Prácticamente todo de él
Quizás hasta demasiado por eso no vamos
a volver a contaros la telenovela que
llevamos 30 años viendo repetida una y
otra y otra vez evidentemente hablamos
de un historial que ha perjudicado su
imagen pública pero lo verdaderamente
llamativo de Carlos es su tendencia a
expresar sus opiniones sobre asuntos de
lo más diverso una tendencia que ha
llegado incluso a provocar algún que
otro incidente diplomático queréis algún
ejemplo pues fijaos un desaire
deliberado el príncipe Carlos se saltará
al banquete con el presidente siguemping
Carlos es partidario del dalai Lama el
líder espiritual tibetano exiliado aquí
en China consideran separatista
peligroso china nunca ha sido vista con
buenos ojos por Carlos III sin ir más
lejos el pasado mes de agosto de este
2022 señaló que Beijing debe contaminar
menos para que la lucha contra el cambio
climático pueda tener éxito y es que
hablamos de un soberano que como
príncipe ha tenido siempre opiniones muy
claras
por ejemplo el calentamiento global
Siempre fue una de las grandes
preocupaciones de este príncipe de gales
pero no la única también ha sido un gran
defensor del reciclaje y desde hace
décadas tiene su propia marca de
alimentos orgánicos sí la preservación
del ecosistema es toda una prioridad
para este monarca y cuando hablamos de
ecosistema nos referimos tanto al medio
ambiente como las propias tradiciones y
la cultura local porque Carlos III se
atreve con todo arremetió incluso con un
proyecto para ampliar la National
gallery porque el edificio propuesto era
demasiado moderno Mirad
single
challenge
Al final este proyecto no salió adelante
pero lo que respecta a Carlos i está
claro que el papel de Príncipe no es
exactamente el mismo que el de Rey
pensando bien decir que hay algo que no
te gusta Te coloca directamente en
frente de los que no opinan igual y a
los windsors lógicamente les conviene
que todos los británicos les
identifiquen como sus Reyes como un
símbolo del Estado equiparable a la
bandera y al himno y por eso podría ser
un problema si llegado el caso a este
monarca le da por el activismo ya lo fue
cuando el príncipe Carlos se
transformaba en Black Spider la araña
negra
los memorandos Black Spider son una
serie de cartas escritas por el príncipe
Carlos de forma anónima para enviarselas
a primeros ministros y miembros del
gabinete se llaman así por los garabatos
con los que Carlos de Inglaterra trataba
de enfatizar las principales cuestiones
que le preocupaban por ejemplo presionó
a Tony Blair para que no prohibiera la
caza del zorro y recomendó dar Carta
blanca al sacrificio de los tejones para
combatir la tuberculosis del ganado se
atrevía incluso a inmiscuirse en la
guerra de Irak y criticar lo que
considero deficiencias de los
helicópteros leans
sin embargo lo cierto Es que no parece
que vaya a ocurrir a medida que la Reina
Isabel envejecía y consciente de que su
llegada al Trono era cuestión de tiempo
el Eterno Heredero Se ha esforzado por
tranquilizar a los británicos el mismo
lo dijo cuando aún era El Heredero Black
Spider pertenece al pasado cuestión de
incentivos
[Música]
El caso es que Carlos III le ha llegado
el momento de ser rey a una edad en la
que lo habitual para los británicos es
estar bailando los pajaritos en benidorm
o en cualquier otro Rincón del
Mediterráneo que les brinde mucho sol y
mucha playa que un heredero genere dudas
es algo habitual incluso cuando su papel
en la práctica están limitado Claro que
en este caso juega a su favor haber
tenido tanto tiempo para prepararse
ahora le toca gestionar la herencia de
su madre y cuando decimos herencia
Hablamos de una herencia con mayúsculas
atentos
[Música]
elegido por un día
además de la corona la herencia de
Isabel II deja para Carlos III un jugoso
legado el ducado de Lancaster Hablamos
de una cartera de activos negocios
terrenos y propiedades por valor de unos
750 millones de euros Eso sí al
convertirse en monarca Carlos ha pasado
el ducado de cornualles valorado en más
de mil millones de euros a su hijo
William en Nuevo heredero Y es que la
familia real británica No anda
precisamente corta de recursos y de
hecho lo más curioso es quizás el perfil
empresarial que tiene su financiación
por ejemplo los beneficios que generan
la gestión de estos ducados se destinan
a sufragar los gastos privados de los
miembros de la familia real de hecho es
básicamente de este pastizal de donde ha
sacado Carlos el dinero con el que ha
financiado todas sus obras benéficas Oye
no está nada mal Claro que luego está la
auténtica joya de la corona el llamado
Crown State valorado en unos 20 mil
millones de dólares
es el patrimonio público del soberano
una colección de tierras y propiedades
que incluye el hipódromo de ascot una
gran parte del centro de Londres así
como del lecho Marino de Gran Bretaña
teóricamente pertenece a la corona pero
realmente se administra de forma
independiente por una corporación
gestionada por el gobierno el año pasado
sus beneficios fueron de unos 350
millones de euros Pues bien en función
de estos beneficios se calcula la
subvención soberana esto es el dinero
que el país da los Windsor para cubrir
sus gastos de personal sus viajes y el
mantenimiento de los palacios
para que os hagáis una idea normalmente
El Monarca recibe el 15% de las
ganancias del Crown State de los dos
años anteriores Y el gobierno británico
se queda con el resto sin embargo se
acordó que entre 2017 y 2027 la casa
real recibiría el 25% para remodelar el
Palacio de buckingham esto supone que
durante el bienio
2021-2022 están recibiendo unos 100
millones de euros unas cantidades que
posiblemente se incrementarán en los
próximos años porque el Crown State es
una auténtica máquina de hacer dinero
Pero además de verdad no os podéis hacer
una idea de qué manera el viento sopla a
favor de los windsors la Reina Isabel
gana una millonada con los parques
eólicos marinos del Reino Unido así que
aunque la subvención soberana se vuelva
a limitar al 15%, los arrendamientos
marinos para levantar parques eólicos
están llenando a toda velocidad el
tesoro real
y luego al margen de todas estas
cantidades están los gastos de seguridad
de la casa real se estiman en otros 100
millones de euros y son sufragados por
la policía metropolitana no obstante
parece que ahora Carlos III va a reducir
el número de miembros de la familia que
participan en actos oficiales para así
aligerar esta factura sea como sea lo
que es seguro es que esta no es la mayor
de sus preocupaciones porque la cuestión
es que la herencia de su madre también
tiene un gran inconveniente ser
Comparado constantemente con Isabel II y
esto Esto no promete ser nada fácil
que Carlos no despierta las mismas
simpatías que Isabel es algo que la
propia reina conocía perfectamente y por
eso consciente de ello Isabel II se
esforzó mucho en conseguir que su hijo
recibiera el mayor honor que aún
mantiene a nivel internacional ser el
jefe de Wolf Y es que en contra de lo
que mucha gente piensa este cargo no
pertenece a la corona del Reino Unido
sino que es designado por los líderes de
todos los países integrantes de este
particular Club
de hecho la reina no quiso que esta
cuestión quedara en el aire tras su
fallecimiento así que ya en el año 2018
se encargó de dejarlo todo atado y bien
atado el príncipe Carlos será el próximo
jefe de la comonwealth los líderes
estatales cumplen los deseos de la reina
y acuerdan que el príncipe de gales
debería suceder a la monarca y ahora sé
lo que muchos estáis pensando pero a ver
todo esto de la cama en web no es algo
así como la sombra del imperio algo que
se inventaron los British para mantener
la tutela sobre sus antiguas colonias
[Música]
Pues bueno quizás es lo que intentan
transmitir desde Londres pero en
realidad se trata de una organización
internacional como cualquier otra de
hecho actualmente forman parte de la
commonwealth países que no tienen ningún
vínculo histórico con Reino Unido como
gabón mozambique Ruanda y todo
oficialmente esta organización persigue
dos objetivos fortalecer la democracia
entre sus miembros y fomentar el
desarrollo económico El problema es que
no tiene la influencia para conseguir lo
primero y tampoco el dinero para
alcanzar lo segundo algunos Defensores
del brexit intentan presentar de alguna
forma la commonwealth como una
alternativa a la Unión Europea pero está
claro que hablamos de cosas muy
diferentes de hecho hay quien incluso
duda del futuro de esta organización una
vez que ha desaparecido la reina y que
el Reino Unido no parece atravesar sus
mejores momentos evitar este escenario y
reforzar esta organización será el
primer reto que tendrá el nuevo rey en
juego está Ni más ni menos que papel
internacional de los Windsor y sobre
todo buena parte de la influencia
británica pero este no es el único reto
que tiene por delante una crisis más
probable es que alguno de los 15 países
donde los windsors continúan ostentando
la jefatura del Estado traten de
convertirse en una República de qué
países hablamos pues ahora mismo lo
vamos a ver
era de repúblicas
desde luego si algunos de los llamados
reinos de la cama en Wolf se
convirtieran en repúblicas No se podría
culpar a Carlos III la propia Isabel II
vio como 15 países decidieron dar este
paso durante su reinado hablamos de
países como Pakistán Sudáfrica Nigeria
Malta fiji Mauricio y Barbados de hecho
este último la patria de Rihanna se
convirtió en república el pasado
noviembre y Oye por eso de favorecer la
normalidad en el proceso al acto asistió
el entonces príncipe Carlos Pues bien El
caso es que los actuales 15 reinos de la
cama Wells hay uno que tiene especial la
versión hacia su nuevo rey alguna idea
Pues fijaos el príncipe Carlos respaldó
El polémico despido del Primer Ministro
australiano revela una carta esta carta
salió la luz en el 2020 y hace
referencia a uno de los episodios más
oscuros de la historia de la tierra
natal de cocodrilo tandil la crisis
constitucional de 1975
[Música]
resulta que el Gobernador general de
Australia el representante de la
monarquía británica para ejercer las
funciones del jefe de estado destituyó
al Primer Ministro laborista el gobierno
atravesaba por aquel entonces su momento
de profunda debilidad y el gobernador
acabó con él de un plumazo nombró Primer
Ministro al líder de la oposición y dio
inicio a 8 años de gobierno de la
coalición entre liberales y
conservadores muchos consideraron que el
Gobernador sabía sobrepasado extra
limitado completamente sus funciones Y
eso eso despertó un fuerte sentimiento
republicano Eso sí en 1999 tuvieron su
oportunidad El gigante de Oceanía
celebró un referéndum para convertirse
en República pero el intento fracasó por
10 puntos sin embargo dos décadas
después la publicación de esta
correspondencia privada que sugiere que
la monarquía británica ejercía una
influencia considerable en la política
australiana ha dado argumentos renovados
a un bloque republicano que lleva
liderando las encuestas bastantes años
de para 2021 Los partidarios del sistema
monárquico llegaron a caer hasta el
28%. con todo el jubileo de platino de
la reina y todos los homenajes tras su
fallecimiento parece que han vuelto a
equilibrar algo las cosas La pregunta es
será una especie de efecto champagne
pues ahí tenéis otro reto
sea como sea hoy por hoy Parece
improbable que en el corto plazo los
republicanos consigan su objetivo ya que
además de una mayoría a nivel nacional
tendrían que lograr también la mayoría
en al menos cuatro de los seis estados
federales de Australia Algo similar
ocurre en Canadá si este país quisiera
deshacerse de la monarquía necesitaría
conseguir el llamado consentimiento
unánime esto es Ni más ni menos que
lograr una mayoría de la cámara de los
comunes el senado y las 10 legislaturas
provinciales vamos que parece más
factible que los británicos echen a los
Windsor de buckingham Palace Antes de
que los canadienses decidan convertirse
en una República Claro que otros países
lo tendrían mucho más sencillo
en Nueva Zelanda bastaría una ley del
parlamento para eliminar la monarquía
pero su primera ministra ya sin darder
ha descartado que dar este paso este
entre sus planes a corto plazo Asimismo
muchos países del Caribe también podrían
volverse republicanos sin realizar un
referéndum sin embargo en el pasado
varios estados no han cumplido sus
promesas de hacerlo como Jamaica en 2009
San Vicente y Las Granadinas celebra un
referéndum republicano que fracasó igual
que había fracasado un año antes
embarbados Claro que en este último caso
al final Barbados optó por convertirse
en República mediante una enmienda
constitucional aprobada por dos tercios
de su parlamento
[Música]
y más de unos preguntaréis Y qué pasan
Reino Unido Acaso no hay republicanos o
qué Pues la verdad es que hasta el
momento el apoyo la monarquía
parlamentaria se mantiene con una sólida
ventaja de tres frente a uno
[Música]
Así mismo la figura del monarca es la
institución más respetada en todo Reino
Unido porque ya sabemos que soy algo que
decepciona los británicos son sus
políticos y además no olvidemos que aún
con todas sus limitaciones la casa real
sigue siendo un poderoso mecanismo de
influencia internacional Al fin y al
cabo compartir jefatura del estado con
Australia Canadá o Nueva Zelanda Oye
pues no está nada mal para mantener
vivos los vínculos políticos sociales
culturales y económicos de hecho tras el
brexit este puede convertirse en el gran
papel de la casa real y de momento la
jefatura de la cama en Wells no es poca
cosa así que Oye pues hace bien el
gobierno en proteger la monarquía y de
hecho la nueva líder del ejecutivo no ha
tardado ni un minuto en evitar cualquier
tentación de que Carlos III se
convirtiera de nuevo en la Black Spider
el Rey Carlos no Existirá a la Cumbre
climática por consejo detrás pero llegas
hasta aquí la pregunta es para todos
vosotros creéis que Carlos III será un
buen rey pensáis que muchos reinos de la
commonwealth intentarán convertirse en
repúblicas al faltar una figura tan
emblemática como Isabel II qué peso
tendrá el nuevo monarca en la política
Internacional del Reino Unido post
brexit podéis dejarnos vuestras
respuestas en los comentarios como
siempre si te ha gustado este vídeo No
olvides darle al botón de like y no
olvides suscribirte a visualpolitik si
es que aún no lo has hecho un saludo y
hasta la próxima
[Música]